great thank you ryan appreciate it and
it's
my pleasure today that we have michael
berry with us i'm michael is the
consultant professor
at stanford d school for the design
school and uh
today's format is maybe a little
different from what some of you
who attend these sessions may be used to
michael and i are going to have a
conversation about design thinking and
specifically
not only some background on design
thinking but also how that plays in the
world of more of a
process centered of an environment but
to start with michael share a little bit
about your background it's quite
interesting and
how you've gotten to the d school and
also some of the things that you do
beyond that
yeah the um the the d school is an
interesting venture
um i have taught at stanford a course
called need finding for
a lot of years and the d-school was a
venture at stanford that said let's
let's figure out how we not just teach
engineers and designers but start
teaching other branches of engineering
other areas of the school about this
thing called design
with the belief that we can help
whatever you're doing whether it's
biochemistry or computer science with
the skills that designers have
so that was kind of the starting point
for the d
great so in terms of um your background
you
teach these school and for those who
haven't had a chance to see that it's a
non-traditional interesting place the
philosophy behind that in terms of this
interdisciplinary approach and bringing
together
it's rather unique even at stanford but
also uh in general
yeah the the core philosophy in the the
d
is that people learn best by doing and
that they've created an environment that
you basically build and develop
design thinking skills through project
work
and project work things that are
important
not just to you but to essentially a
larger community things are going to
make a difference
there's an enormous push about this idea
is extreme collaboration
everything is done um in teams
with the belief that at the end of the
day you are going to go out and work
with teams so
how do you really be creative in groups
so that's really essential
in terms of my own practice i also do a
course in the d
called cross-cultural design where we
take
and partner with peking university and
do an exchange between
stanford engineering students peaking
university engineering students and have
them
solve a problem that has to work in both
cultures
in terms of background uh i work with
lots of
marketers designers engineers business
people
um i have gotten the chance to do design
research in lots of different countries
and for lots of different kinds of work
whether it's
product service new category development
and
as i said for a lot of different
companies
and companies that are both high-tech
consumable
non-profits and entities around the
world so it's kind of this background
that we want to share with our students
the belief that
these are tools that can be applied in a
lot of different contexts
where innovation and creativity is
essential that's what you want to get
out of it at the end
but it's going to be applied in sort of
non-traditional potentially
we're going to have computer science
people biochem
educators they need create
they need that sense of seeing the world
differently just as much as a designer
who has to come up with a new
new iphone i think that's it it brings
up an interesting
you know when we talk about what is
design thinking i think there's a sense
out there particularly in the
in this more process environment the
world of project program management
the sense that design thinking is a
product uh you know
product designers it's the ideas of the
world it's the apples
and um i know just kind of a side note
we were chatting and
you once had an interesting question
what came first innovation or design
thinking someone asked i'm just kind of
curious maybe you could provide a little
yeah certainly there is a lot of buzz
about design thinking and it feels like
maybe is it a fad
or a trend um i would say it's a really
good question
innovation is essentially the the thing
we're interested in and we have always
had innovation
and i think what design thinking is
looking at is how do we
um increase the chance that we're going
to get
interesting compelling innovation more
often
and just to clarify um it's easy to
mistake invention for innovation
and invention is coming up with
something new
and the patent offices are full of
wonderful new things that nobody wants
part of innovation and part of the
foundation of innovation is
that that new thing fits into our world
makes that world in some way better
creates new value
satisfies needs which is sort of the
foundation of my course
and design thinking is a way of
more consistently bringing together
the kind of deep knowledge of people and
culture that you need to have
in order to get that invention that's
something new to actually stick
to actually work and uh you know i i
think we came from a place where
we see you know graveyards
products that have failed where we have
put phenomenal
technology energy human
resource and capital and it hasn't
connected
we look at had-based computing and that
was something that we spent 20 30 years
pursuing and we just got it right
we just got it right and i think the
foundation here is how can we
more consistently get it right and
that's where design thinking came from
um
it's it's interesting i think again in
terms of some people who may say well
how does this fit in a world
particularly
we've got a lot of individuals who
participate in the advanced project
management program that come from a
world of i
we're going to talk about that yeah but
if you think about
we're all chartered with thinking more
innovatively looking at more
creative ways to implement and quite
frankly it's that
transition to adoption which often is
what undermines the successful
completion
of initiatives or projects and speaking
to that and i think
there's a parallel let's explore design
thinking a little bit more and sure
understanding it we'd like to to take a
little bit and
i think um you know we've talked a
little bit about design thinking not
being
just for uh designers and and maybe why
it's a bit relevant beyond just product
design
um but maybe uh before we jump into an
overview
to to a way of thinking about that and
some of the framework and tools
um share a little bit more about why you
see that kind of the relevancies
and potentially
let me ask this a little differently if
you think about where you've seen this
applied what what's kind of the most
seemingly out there kind of way that
design thinking was applied that someone
wouldn't have thought
this is how this isn't a place where
design thinking can benefit
yeah i think it's kind of a curveball
question no
i would say um and i'm gonna use
an example um
i don't know if it's unusual but it i'm
gonna i
started talking about iphones and ipads
and um
for a lot of years we kind of looked at
the kind of single functionality of
pad is it a computer is it simply a
smaller version and then we we threw
telephony on top of it and what was
fascinating
and steve jobs gets a lot of credit at
being a visionary
certainly was but he was very opposed to
the idea that
the iphone and the apps be an open
source system
he really wanted it to be owned
and a lot of people in the company felt
very differently
and steve at that time had
liver replacement so he wasn't on scene
and
suddenly the apps became something that
a set of tools that could be shared were
created and offered to a larger
community
and if i had to say what is the success
of that platform
it is the ability not of apple
to be unbelievably creative
and yes apple has been but it's the
ability to offer the tools to now just
not
a hundred designers a thousand designers
we now have a set of tools that a
million
designers are looking at their lives
understanding them and going i now have
a medium that i can fix what what's
going on with me
and i can offer it back out the iphone
and apple's success
in large measure came from something
that steve was actually very opposed to
that that ability to share right
the creativity with non-designers and
yet
that is a phenomenal and you talk to any
manufacturing company at this point in
asia u.s japan and it's not the hardware
it's not the hardware it's the apps and
it's because the apps create experiences
and their experiences that you cannot
get elsewhere and that's where the real
value is
so in this sense suddenly that
shift of taking what was simply an
app that presumably could have been
owned and controlled by apple and if you
look at all the other predecessors
they'd try to really bound that
and suddenly it became an open source
creative way of solving everybody's
problems
and that to me is an interesting example
where
suddenly needs and
leveraging everyone's creative design
thinking
became an unbelievable success and at
the end of the day apple still owns it
apple still that kind of valence
of success of creativity of coolness
still comes back to them so it's an
interesting
sense of as i said we like to think
about design thinking as a combination
of creativity and analytic thinking
going back and forth between those but
we're always grounded in a deep
knowledge
and the fascinating thing about apps is
it is everyone's own first person
experience that gets it started
and it's at a scale that i can do
something about it
so i think it's a great transition as we
as we look at
um design thinking and dive a little
deeper in terms of defining it
share with us a little bit we've got um
five
different uh statements that may look
like statements uh that focus
yeah but they're not statements they're
much more than that
yeah um so it's also easy we talk about
there is a design process or a design
thinking process and if we
teach the process engage the process out
we'll pop
amazing things and of course as anybody
who's taken an engineering course right
you know learning the the process
of you know determining stress and
strength doesn't necessarily mean you're
going to be able to do it well
so i think what we've seen is within
design thinking the process is actually
less important meaning the stepping
through a
tightly described set of activities then
a set of really important tools
that are going to be used by a group a
little more intuitively
a little more in response to the
situation they find themselves in and
those
those tools as you said are something
more they're kind of a foundation
of um thinking about problems
differently
and essentially getting around a lot of
the stumbling blocks that more
traditional analytic thinking
some systems thinking can get grouped
into
where they often aren't they box
themselves in
and by the way we we believe design
thinking is on top of those other modes
of thinking
critical thinking systems thinking all
very very important
but it's how do we do better it's a yes
and phenomena right
yes to those things and this as well so
first one
and it's this idea of observing with
empathy
that sense of not just being an expert
knowing the answers but seeing
what is very difficult to see and is
always around you
these are the rules and norms that guide
people's lives often guide yours lives
and the point is you can't change things
until you can see them clearly
so a lot of what we teach is how do you
see that world you're in
see the things that go without being
stated that you take for granted are
almost invisible to you
and it's often the most difficult to see
things that are the most important to
innovation creating value
and we find clues we find clues
and those clues lead to insights and
that gets to the next
next thing which is this idea of asking
why
um in a university that's actually a
really hard question to ask
we got here because we knew the answers
so to ask
those dumb questions those questions of
what seems obvious but maybe really
really critical
that's actually a skill we have to teach
and this sense
of insights come from not just
a flash although on occasion those
flashes happen and it's delightful when
they do
but there's also building all of the
models
that help you see the complexity of the
world you've just explored
hopefully reveal white space so lots and
lots of
different approaches to modeling the
world and being able to ask
why why do things that don't exactly
make sense
make sense um one thing and
i think there's a very strong push
towards data and data analytics
the difficulty there is you're often
dealing only
with correlation this deals with
causality
why is something happening and that you
often have to get
into people's lives you have to get your
hands dirty you got to explore
um and this gets into
oh go ahead oh no
these first two you know it's very
interesting in terms of
even if we're developing a new system
uh you know we seem to know what the
requirements are there's a
often a standard kind of approach to
doing that there's gates we pass through
we develop something and then we get to
the other end and again when it's time
to hand it off
and and see people start using it and
get full adoption
that's often where the resistance and
barrier becomes and it seems
it seems to me that our ability to
really think a little differently
looking for those
insights gathering that data and
potentially a different way
can help us kind of unearth what some of
those issues are that aren't necessarily
the technical requirements it's more
about how people are really going to use
it how's it going to save something
save time or improve efficiency or work
better but also even a common interface
might end up your your comment about
kind of receiving
a set of product specs and getting to
work is
a challenge because most of our
engineers are very good at doing that
most of our classes structure kind of
work
that way the difference here is we also
want our students to go
is that the right problem to be solving
what are the goals and i got the product
the problem you gave me but maybe it
isn't the most important problem to be
solving to get at what you want
to what is in fact the goal of the
project
so that's in this asking why we're not
just asking why of the outside world
from research we're also turning it
inward
and that sense of coming up with a very
different set
of criteria and perhaps
one of those criteria is is this the
best question
to get at what you want so that's a new
set of skills that
we believe we're giving to our students
um another one and this is
um there's a very strong practice
to get to the answer we tend to create
convergers people who want to get to an
answer quickly efficiently effectively
and move on what you find is you get
good ideas
you need to have a lot of ideas and that
ability to diverge
to be able to creatively
solve a problem from many different
points of view and some of those points
of view are different perspectives
to be able to really
have a group use their skills
their ability to come at the problem as
i said if you've got a biologist
and somebody who is an educator and an
engineer
and a business person together they're
going to solve that problem in different
way and if they
are only converging coming to a single
answer you're not going to get the
benefit
of that group mind that said you do have
to know how to converge
right in that sense of of determining
what is not just the best answer because
we often
do processes where who's going to win
and the
big point of the design thinking is to
essentially
build the best answer out of these many
answers
how do you find elements of both that
will create the best solution to where
you want to go and that's
as much about team dynamics as it is
about putting out lots of post-its and
voting um some of the other things this
gets to
another piece that's central to design
thinking central to our program and i
mentioned getting your hands
uh it's both getting getting out in
people's environments but
then putting solutions very low res
solutions
very early out into people's hands to
begin to evaluate your thinking
um we have a tendency to not want
to iterate
and create lots of solutions we want to
get perfect solution and what we found
is really important is it takes a lot of
courage to get your initial ideas out
try them out and iterate iterate a lot
um and that sense of being able to
creatively
find ways to ask key questions
of your service or product or process
that you want to develop
and test those very very early on
the disaster we've seen over and over
where immense amount
of money are poured in and the
fundamentals haven't actually
been understood so this is about getting
those fundamentals
understood tested and having a team
involved in those
and your resolution starts to change as
you start to build more knowledge
through iterative cycles um the last
piece
and this idea of storytelling making
ideas compelling and it seems like well
isn't that
something that's more of an advertiser's
job or isn't that what you do
with the final powerpoint when you want
to pitch your idea to the venture guys
and
what we found is narrative
and storytelling is essential both in
data collection
meaning i need to understand stories
people
will understand and communicate very
complex ideas through stories
stories are a way of making sense of the
data the other piece though
is being able to
craft a story of your idea
of your service of what you're doing and
change behavior
because if you've gone through all of
this have a fantastic idea
and it doesn't affect the organization
you're in
or the community around you you've
wasted your time and everybody else's
so this notion of how does narrative and
telling tie all this together is
critical and this kind of creates an
interesting
and interesting
interesting set of tools it looks like a
messy process but i would argue it isn't
and it appears messy because it isn't
always the same
but that i think is essential to kind of
the creative nature
of of what we're after and it's it's
really
it's an iterative process in terms of
there is a process here but i think of
you know user uh use use cases yes
more standard ways push on that and
think about for instance storytelling
that
that's an element of that that can be
applied up front
yes as well as when you're looking to
gain acceptance throughout the process
and then when you're looking for
implementation
so i think the opportunity for people to
think about
you know as you've mentioned look at the
tools recognize how they build but also
how they can be used in different
kind of at different times and different
ways you could not be so locked into
i can't do i can't generate ideas
certainly we want to
uh you know diverge and then converge
absolutely absolutely there's tools here
that can be used and employed at
different times
that's exactly right that is exactly
right and
i think the goal in as you said the
d-school
and what we're doing through this sort
of project-based learning is you need to
practice using these
and you need to practice not in
artificial situations but where you got
skin in the game where it matters
so we it's a little off of what we plan
to talk about today but
maybe share with people just um i've
had the opportunity to not only uh work
and see
at the d school but also we have the the
class and the program you know
innovation through design thinking talk
a little more about that
importance of rolling up your sleeves
and and
and actually kind of doing and
committing the time but i i think of
maybe paint a little picture of what
happens even when we're in that class
um because i think it's quite a
different way of thinking
and and you know i'm smiling because i'm
thinking about you know
people come i had i had a friend that
said oh you're just uh you know teaching
kindergartners and there's something to
that though
so yeah that's it's a funny one because
you are
not wrong uh a lot of the elements of it
have looked a little like kindergarten
on the surface
on the surface and i but i think um
what we have found by
putting people in situations where they
need to
solve a problem that they have no idea
how to get through
most of the problems we face these days
start that way at least the interesting
ones do
and that ability to discover in yourself
what does an insight feel like where you
actually see something you thought you
knew differently
has a very powerful shift in by stepping
out by using these tools in different
ways by loosening up
i suddenly was smarter than i thought it
was
a lot of people and when i say that it's
the notion that this
i wouldn't have been able to do this
before
i tried some of this stuff out before i
was willing to let a team
interact with me in these kinds of ways
before i was willing
to go i'm really anxious i need to get
to that answer as fast as i can
taking the deep breath getting a large
range of answers
using some tools and starting to see
patterns i never
thought i could get to before and what
we've seen over and over is the quality
of your work
changes and we've done this a lot of
companies who've evaluated
work on design thinking and work off
design thinking and what is not
just did it get done on time but
is the quality of what was put out
better is it satisfying needs is it
making us
money more effectively and we've seen
over and over
that the stuff that designers used to
use to
to create stuff can be used by lots of
people
and it's everything and we love it
this we started out uh
some of the tools and i'm thinking about
we we do a tool called mind mapping
where you basically have something you
want to think about
and i need to make all the connections
about
this thing and whether it's shopping or
you know
a carbon carbon atom you basically go
through and empty your mind and lay it
out and it's a nice way of making
connections and you go all the way out
to you just start
literally asking questions and we had
kenny's who would
take the tool go back home to their fume
hoods
and they'd be working on a problem and
somebody would start mind mapping
and their buddy would what what are you
doing
what are you doing right now on the
field and i think i i i think i've got
i've got it i've got it this this links
to this
oh yeah that's that's one of those
design thinking things like where do i
get some of that yeah
so what we've seen is
you can take your kind of current set of
skills
current set of thinking and you can do
the yes and build on them with some of
the tools and just
do a little better i think what's
fascinating though
is that larger practice and as i said if
you're an engineer it takes years to get
good at it
but as you start to get good at a
collection of these tools
as you start to uh inform
and and then really energize groups
you start getting to much more
interesting things more regularly and
when i say interesting things
it's small scale usability stuff right i
need to have a new way of helping
seniors you know let others know when
they fall
all the way to very large scale complex
problems so we
see this getting getting used throughout
that that that continuum
yeah so really a couple things that
really strike me the the yes and
building upon
ways of doing things currently but also
there is this this
you know need to invest the time the
energy
but also to try things on to create this
environment which is what happens
i've seen with different you know groups
and teams that you've worked with
so they can try these tools and figure
out you know some of them may be
applicable some may not
where they occur and the like and uh
just to transition a little bit
um you know to to explore just maybe
some some insights i think you you
recently wrote an article
that was quite interesting and and it uh
it based on some research you did and
and you know when we think about how we
apply design thinking in more of a
process heavy environment
sure um there's kind of a way of
thinking
or kind of a key insight and there's
many but one in particular i thought
maybe we could dive into a little bit
this issue about
framing and reframing and then you have
three major findings that i think would
be interesting for folks to hear
yeah so so for me the real power
of design thinking this is kind of
laddering up from the tools as you said
is my ability to reframe a problem i've
got and when i said our students will
challenge is that the right problem to
be solving that's kind of the core of a
reframing
it's that sense of you don't just accept
what you got
i can see it from different ways and
there's some advantages
to to doing that so for example
and i think kind of the next slide um
sometimes you basically need more
solutions
i just don't have enough solutions
uh and if i had more solutions my senses
i'd probably have a have a a a better
end result
and a classic example of this is uh if
someone
says you know i need a bridge i need a
ch here from stanford engineering right
give me and if you accept that
you could build a suspension bridge you
know
cantilever bridge but your solutions are
going to be all within a bridge space
lots of bridges different kinds but all
bridges
and here's he asked why why why do you
need a bridge
the answer may be i i need to get across
the river
and now suddenly the solution space
changes
it changes from bridges to maybe a boat
would work
maybe if i start looking at the river
and your skills maybe you can swim
across point being
there's a very different solution space
and if i ask why again
writing need to get across a river the
answer is well i i need to tell somebody
on the other side
something really important now the
solution space changes again
so my point these are all ways of
getting to a reframe
each y question opens it up and
effectively
reframes the problem that you um
because you were simply given the
problem and didn't question it you
may be answering the wrong question
right so
that's one so what i just gave you is i
need
more answers to a problem the easy way
to get it that
asking why over and over framing it
differently
different answers come so that's kind of
the starting point and sort of the
simplest way we think of the advantages
of design thinking just
to get more ideas well i i think that
just a
one more thought on that is that again
in a process driven environment so often
as you
alluded to earlier we're given here's
what we
here's the problem yeah go solve it
here's a system that we currently have
or one that we need to create to meet
this need
and uh recognizing that the
you know culturally and environmentally
the organization you work in there can
be some pushback
but really the value of asking why
and to look looking at at different ways
of framing can often lead to the fact
that
we don't create a you know we don't
build it and nobody comes at the end
because that wasn't really the system
that we needed or that really didn't
address the issue that was
exactly right and actually what you just
said kind of leads to the next
issue uh and the next one is you
actually cannot solve the problem as it
is framed
you just can't get there from here um
and classic and one that came out of my
work
um we were working with sure microphone
and sure sells microphones to the
largest seller of microphones in the
world and they sell them to a lot of
rock musicians and they noted
that um the customers their rock
musicians were losing their hearing
and that's kind of a catastrophe and
losing it in really unpleasant ways
tinnitus ringing in the ears so they
were concerned
how do we help our customers how do we
protect them
and they believed that if they provided
a kind of
earplug that could let them hear and
essentially take them to an audiologist
and get a what was seen as a
prophylactic solution
something that could reduce sound levels
and protect their hearing
um this would be a really important
thing to do
huge need huge need and when we tried it
out
musicians went no effing way am i
putting
right a hearing that's horrible i won't
do it i won't do it
and sure initially was like this is
really discouraging right
they don't want it and again if you
think of a musician as a you know
16 year old rock gods don't wear hearing
aids okay what's fascinating was the
reframe and as we asked
this was a displacement where we asked
people to go through a period of time of
trying out some rough prototypes all the
way to getting them
to perform in front of an audience they
started to discover a lot of things
about their own performance that these
things gave them they didn't know
one actually couldn't hear themselves on
stage
suddenly i could hear myself suddenly
with a wireless system i could move
around on
stage and i wasn't locked to the little
speaker that was the only thing i could
hear
uh the engineers on stage loved it
because now suddenly i wasn't getting
feedback
between the on stage speakers and
microphones suddenly
the whole ecosystem started to change
and we could solve the problem
of hearing protection the final result
we never
ever talked about hearing protection
ever
that would kill the project but the
reframe around performance
did a whole suite of solutions of new
processes
uh it changed how musicians play on
stage
and yes within the last six years rates
of hearing loss among musicians have
gone down
so it worked but the reframe was
critical and if you
led with that initial frame the problem
wasn't solvable
very interesting yeah
there's one more piece that we wanted to
touch on uh there was a third element
here
and share a little bit about that so we
are in a changing world um
it's a changing world both from
increase of technological horsepower
processing power is doubling every 16
months
we are having environmental issues that
are seem insurmountable um
social issues customers expecting
far more not just a product or a service
but i want to be
transformation so this is a world you're
working in and suddenly
your solutions need to
operate in essentially uh unbounded
space
a lot of different elements come
together we refer to these as wicked
problems
and if you are doing anything
interesting today
it's going to have some aspect of that
wicked problem
and we believe that design thinking is a
really
important way to begin to
creatively find threads find
solutions that can pull
all the aspects of that problem that
have to work together
all right if you take it apart you may
not be able to get it
put back together again right meaning
take it apart
solve everything independently put it
back together design thinking
is very useful at um
solving problems in total getting that
first
half through the problem suddenly i get
it i see how the whole piece can work
together
doesn't mean you're not going to go back
and use those other tools
to refine it to really get it right
but creatively helping people
engage wicked problems we found is one
of the more powerful
powerful things that design thinking
offers us
and so this this changing uh
one element and the way it affects
others so
focusing on that not being afraid to
take on the wicked problem but then
kind of playing with different aspects
engaging with different aspects rather
than
yeah it's a sense of the kind of systems
problems we're looking at are ecologies
right and whether it's dealing with
culture this mythology or our own
apology um and if you come from a world
where i have an
engine i can optimize the engine by
taking apart and putting it back
together and it's going to work every
time
that's great unfortunately that's not
the
environment you live in and the problems
you are wrestling with as a business
right that's a service as a non-profit
policy uh
steve jobs iphone and those apps
address that very complicated ecosystem
and suddenly
lots of people were now able to engage
that complex ecosystem in ways that
a single company and a few designers
could
ever ever imagine so
we have some hopes that um design
thinking in conjunction with
other disciplines other deep knowledge
and skill
will help us get it some of these wicked
problems that are
both scary but they also represent if
you look at it right
really really interesting opportunity
great we have gotten
a host of questions want to thank
everybody who's on the line and has
forwarded those to us we're going to
take a few minutes now i'm going to pass
it back
to ryan chin ryan's got some information
we'd like to share and then we're going
to come back and take a few of those
questions
thank you michael so first of all let me
thank uh
tim and michael that was really
enjoyable i also want to thank all our
participants for being here today
do want to remind you that we we
probably won't be able to get to all the
questions
and we thank you so much for submitting
those uh thank you for participating
today
one last reminder that we are recording
this and we will send out a link to
the to this recording or to this
presentation and webinar so you can
watch it later
let me tell one one quick story where i
believe that
i had deep knowledge but it was the
creativity that michael was able to
bring to an experience
so i he he did a a design thinking
exercise and they applied it to
the performance evaluation it was maybe
the most enjoyable way i've ever looked
at
performance evaluations and to rethink
that experience and if you have one day
maybe you'll see the video it was
just terrific and it actually made me
rethink how i given and provided for
performance evaluations
again my name is ryan chin i'm with the
stanford center for professional
development
just to tell you a little bit about our
center who is presenting this webinar
today
we consider ourselves a bridge between
stanford and industry and that means
that we
we extend stanford education both
graduate programs and professional
education
to working professionals and we've been
doing this for 45 years
on the graduate side what we do is we
actually allow people to
watch stanford graduate programs and
these can be in the disciplines through
the school of engineering
and in fact you can earn a degree in
electrical engineering
uh computer science and manual science
initiative completely at a distance
and we also take the same research and
and teachings that our faculty do in
their graduate courses and in their
research
and we turn those into professional
education courses and those are short
courses
more focused materials our most
popular and most successful professional
education
program has been the stanford advanced
project management program and one of
the reasons i think that this program
has
been particularly successful is our
partnership with ips learning
and that that partnership has allowed us
not only to take what
the work of our faculty professor ray
levitt is the academic director of this
program
but also take ips uh experience in
industry
and really make this a powerful
combination of both experience and
research
and so we are now in our 15th year over
near 6 000 graduates
and so i i think it speaks to the power
of this program
the program is based on you can see the
set of courses here
there are three core courses and then
you'll take three elective courses
our newest elective course is project
innovation through design thinking
we're talking about design thinking
today and this course actually is being
offered
in a new model through our online
courses
and will be offered this september here
on campus it's our only time that we
offer we offer courses on campus
twice a year and this this september
will be the one time that we're offering
projects to find innovation through
design thinking so if you're interested
do i want to recommend that you sign up
quickly it it will sell out
so at this point i'm going to ask if i
have your interest in the stanford
advanced project management program
so i'm going to open the poll up now and
if you can please
remember to submit your answers i'll
give you a few moments
and so while you're voting i'll just
i'll just tell you the the video that
michael showed the the session that
michael was doing on
through the
performance evaluations and how this one
he challenged
they were challenged the group was
challenged to to make a skit about it
and it was just the most enlightening
way of how to approach
and view that idea all right at this
point i think i'm going to just go ahead
and again thank you so much for
submitting your answers
i'm going to go ahead and close the poll
at this point
thank you so much and i'm going to
remind you that
the stanford advanced project management
program is offered in three different
modes
so again we teach it here at stanford
that's in march and september
we typically hold it over two weeks and
so if you want to go to the website and
the website's down
the website is apm.stanford.edu
once again apm.stanford.edu you can also
see
the contact information there these
courses are offered online
throughout the year we um
allowing you to take the courses
asynchronously and at your own pace
and then through our partner we also
offer the network and so
if you want to have them delivered we
have them delivered at many many places
throughout the country and around fact
across the world so
if you're interested in that we actually
you'll actually need to contact us and
we can
and talk to us about how it can be done
at this point i'm going to turn it back
over to tim and michael to answer a few
questions
all right and with that
let's see all right uh so michael
looking at the
first question is kind of an intriguing
one actually just gets to more of a
kind of personal level so how do you
account for
introverted individuals i mean i kind of
made a a joke earlier because i get some
teasing from some of some of my friends
outside of work about this design
thinking thing you're just going and
playing with toys but
you know the reality is i think many you
know particularly technical
professionals they're
there maybe are a little more on the
introverted side so
um kind of it does rely on everyone's
involved
you know what are your thoughts on that
no and i uh that
question is very close to my own heart
uh all evidence to the contrary i'm
actually an introvert
um and with the definition that um i'm
not energized by groups i love groups
but boy
need to need to find that quiet and to
get to this
idea um and certainly a lot of the
public presentation of design thinking
it's very active it seems very social
and boy you have to be out there all the
time
the reality is as you use these
different tools especially
we've found understanding
people and using divergent thinking
meaning
i really need to understand people from
many different ways
introverts are much better at doing that
than extroverts all right introverts are
able to
go inside and begin to see a lot of the
different ways something could happen
uh the other piece that's interesting
most introverts that
model abstractly right so we're taking
reality and we're going to model it in
many different ways
introverts are very very good at doing
this so
you find is within a team that
begins to explore different tools and
recognize
people that essentially and these tools
right you said they're more they are
thinking skills
um those thinking skills um
can both be emphasized within the group
and if a group understands that that
skill is different than how i approach
the problem so we spend a fair amount of
time helping groups understand
that as i go through this problem
they're going to be different thinking
skills they're going to be emphasized
and some of those skills are going to be
served much better by introverts who may
in fact be
leading effort because they are the best
at doing it
and as you get to converging where i
need to
have that leadership and make that final
decision right
the extroverts come back once more but
it is absolutely a balance between those
things
and we have found that you you need to
have everybody
everybody involved in both types
absolutely critical of a process
great excellent insight
you know it's somewhat related but but
really
um you know there is for for all the
excitement about the the promise of
design thinking and the successes we're
seeing with
it i think there also can be kind of
this skepticism
uh even i may make light of you know
friends
tease me a little bit but in seriousness
they respect it but leadership sometimes
thinks
you know you alluded to it earlier we've
got a problem get cut to the chase
figure it out solve it move on be
efficient
so so it almost gets to how do we help
convince uh it's not just leadership but
often there's a perception
how do we get people who don't really
understand this to be supportive of it
so because it does have implications for
more time i think particularly on the
front end although even
fundamental project management says plan
plan plan before you jump in and do it
on some element but the reality is we've
got that tension about move fast you
know we've got to be agile and and
move more quickly yet um so anyhow i i
think i
threw a few things in there no uh and i
have to say our experience
in kind of corporate america adopting it
um
and we've we've seen it operate in a
couple different ways
um and stepping back i gave the example
of the chemies with their fume hoods and
mind mapping was an interesting way at
stanford where it was by small examples
small everyday examples of using parts
of this
that we started to build credibility and
people started to engage
larger and larger parts of the process
um in corporate america we've seen it
kind of operate a little differently
where uh
and i'll give deloitte as an example
they did a pretty extensive program
where they looked at
six ongoing projects three of them and
they actually repeated it twice
three of the programs had were done
independent design thinking done in a
traditional way
three of the programs on design thinking
and um
they then repeated it for another
another six just to kind of validate
the response and what they found was
overwhelmingly
the and some of the problems were
problems that had been tried before and
failed
the design thinking got them through it
in different ways
the quality of work was different
some of the problems around audit that
seemed insurmountable
because you if you frame it in a certain
way it cannot be changed
but reframing it actually found they
could shift things that
they thought were these are orthodoxies
that are immutable
we can start to get around things so i
actually found the design thinking
uh to give better results the teams seem
to
uh be much more effective uh both in the
the problem solving component and the
rollout
so um this was my point of it was
they essentially did their own internal
experiment it wasn't simply a workshop
where i try it there's no skin in the
game all the participants their jobs are
on the line
this wasn't this was business as usual
at deloitte
so i think that's the piece we've seen
um if there is skin in the game where i
take this stuff seriously
and they can't simply go back to
business as usual
i need to follow through on it we have
seen um
learning happen and this is no surprise
this is how we learn anything
but for organizations that's essentially
the challenge you're learning a new set
of skills
initially all of them are not
comfortable or they may seem to fly in
the face of existing orthodoxies
and whether it is top
down i i feel it needs to be experience
based
you can't just do it as an abstract one
day workshop and say now everybody go do
it
it needs to be some level of immersion
where
i've got something at stake and my team
needs to live with this for a period of
time
that seems to be worked best for our
students and for the organizations we've
seen
really really use it yeah
it looks like we've got maybe time for
for one more question oh
yeah this yeah yeah this is a fun one
i'll let you read it
well the question that was posed was why
do you think so many people address the
symptoms by trying to
create a way to offset the symptoms
instead of addressing the problem yeah
really the source and in fact resist in
fact
you know often they're they're they're
not just mis
looking at the wrong issue but they
actually resist
taking on the source of the problem so
i'm gonna
just reference clayton christensen an
innovator's dilemma
uh he did a fascinating fascinating
study on u.s companies that
essentially have crashed have crashed
because to exactly this point they
addressed symptoms and didn't look at
the problem
didn't look at that world around them
and i i think what he
and so essentially it's an issue of
framing but it's an issue of framing
that is not
easy to resolve since often the success
of a company and this is
clayton christensen's premise the
success
keeps you from seeing the world
differently right you have now
framed a world based on your success and
you see
everything in relation to what made you
successful if that world
and its situation is starting to change
you do not see it clearly so we get back
to this seeing the water
and it is not i mean heat paints have
over 100 companies only
one of them was able to change over time
was able to actually innovate more than
once in its existence
that is that is real and his point was
this is a horrendous a horrendous loss
of resource of energy and the failure
happens fast
so actually reframing
is is kind of an essential way to get
out of that innovator's dilemma
we actually we've got about two more
minutes
is there i mean we've mentioned that
certainly is
as part of the program we we have a pro
of course we teach here and design
thinking is popping up in other areas
but people wanted to find out more about
design thinking are there some resources
available
through the d-school or otherwise where
they might be able to learn a little
more about this i think there
is enormous amount of material now
online uh i think both
in forms of video in forms of using
tools i think we're getting a rich
source of people who are documenting
how they're doing this where it's being
used
kind of taking the uh the mysticalism
out of it right this is not
magic right this is this is you know
people relying on a creative intuition
that
may have been maybe gotten a little lazy
with
but it's also kind of showing the power
of of what happens when you
diverge before you converge and you
don't do both at the same time
and it sounds as i said some simple
things like that
can have some some pretty strong changes
another very simple thing we've seen is
what you use to model a problem uh
can often restrict what the possible
solutions turn
you start to model it using some
unexpected things
this classic example for us is we had
students design chairs and we gave them
cardboard and they came out with very
ordinary solutions we gave them pipe
cleaners
and a number of the students said well
this is a horrible material designed to
chair out of the
few started to bend and twist and go i
can come up with a completely different
chair and use the compliance of the
system and do that
and those are all the things we're now
starting to see put out online
as kind of the they seem like
that's a cool trick let me try it out
but it's
part of a larger way of thinking about
um
how to understand customers deeply how
to have a dialogue with them
how to ask why how to diverge in
converge
great thank you michael thank you so
much i think we're about at the end of
our time
you